la rentabilité at elle tué l'hôpital ça
c'est la grosse question eux
alors il ya eu il ya eu d'une deux
choses qui ont tué l'hôpital d'une part
on a décidé que en 2008 en rock
l'hôpital devait être géré comme
cliniques commerciales
ces autres devaient être rentable et on
a dit l'hôpital devient une entreprise
comme les autres
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis des tarifs on
a tous fait rentrer un tarif on l'a
utilisé la tarification à l'activité sur
la facturation comme le ferait une
grande surface 1 est d'ailleurs ensemble
de personnalités comme jean des cars de
didier l'hôpital est une entreprise
commerciale comme les autres qui cherche
à vendre
et puis à partir de 2008 avec la crise
économique
on a mis une contrainte budgétaire alors
on a eu à la fois une contrainte
budgétaire et une gestion commerciale
alors ça ça tu es l'hôpital la clinique
elle peut s'adapter elle choisit ses
activités dit je vais faire de chirurgie
ambulatoire canal carpien la cataracte
son but la cataracte ambulatoire la
prothèse de hanche mais la personne âgée
polypathologiques à maladies chroniques
les troubles cognitifs la dépression les
les interventions complexes je fais pas
voilà donc les urgences je fais pas donc
voilà
l'hôpital a été tué par un couple qui
s'appelle gestion commerciale et
restrictions budgétaires et on en est
pas sorti on commande en demande encore
des économies à l'hôpital alors il ya eu
le ségur qui a augmenté les salaires du
personnel
pas même pas au niveau de la moyenne
ocde mais néanmoins un premier
rattrapage
mais en dehors de ça qui n'a pas changé
le cap qui était fixé contrairement à ce
qu'avait promis le président de la
république
au moment